[Musique]
mais là sans filtre le podcast on parle
de ce qu'on veut nous inviter dati site
super h 30 avec moi de me plante cette
semaine le sans filtre et commanditée
par autres box aux boks en fait c'est un
service d'abonnement mensuel qui
envoient des déjeuners des sacs de
granola comme ça entre autres chez vous
à votre porte à chaque mois moi je
consomme ou de boxe à chaque jour depuis
que j'ai connu les accompagnent en fait
depuis que j'ai collaboré avec eux pour
la première fois au début de l'année
puis puis j'adore ça littéralement c'est
mon seul déjeuner dôme toi tu en es tu
commences à manger des hot boxe le début
que j'en ai un mais saddam échec et je
me suis avec du lait de soya l'amiable
et rue autres permettre ça peut le
manger comme des céréales tu peux te
faire ce que tu veux que ce puits nous
en fait avec votre premier mois
d'abonnement vous offre le deal du
siècle
ces vingt pièces pour trois sacs comme
ce pour un pot maçon pour entretenir
votre granollers pour trois bords des
jeunes et trois sacs de gruau tous ceux
pour une valeur de 45 ya ce fait vous
avez une valeur 45 ya ce pour seulement
20 dollars sur votre premier mois
d'abonnement
c'est vraiment un instit bondir le
quartier de cocody pourquoi pas si vous
utilisez le code sans filtre en
minuscules au check out sur le site web
puis en plus haute box nous avec jessica
qu'on a collaboré avec oddbox on a donné
six ans petit déjeuner au club des
petits déjeuners parce qu'à chaque fois
que quelqu'un soit bonne il donne un
petit déjeuner au club des petits
déjeuners fait que c'est vraiment en
plus de soutenir une bonne cause
pour nourrir des jeunes qui ont besoin
de manger le matin c'est un produit
extraordinaire c'est des amis à moi
aussi c'est vraiment une compagnie
super cool super éthique puis soit pour
dire que aux boks utilise le code promo
sans filtre 20 $ pour 45 dollars
si votre première abonnement le lien
voir n'abaisseront la vidéo sinon dam de
ces salles on a reçu raphaël roy qui la
finale est à la voix tous les touches le
tout frais tout chaud on les mardis on a
donc la finale c'était à variable ça va
sortir dans une semaine
[Musique]
la fait le roi en plus d'être une
chanteuse incroyable à la vraiment une
personnalité gardien je dirais hors du
commun pauvres est venu ici est un drôle
est positive iphone ça a passé en un
clin d'oeil le podcast avant de parler
de son parcours de la voix dans le fonds
commun qu'elle a vécu ce n est pas bien
vécu seraient une belle progression
un fier d'elle et ça a été une
expérience super positif juste positif
aussi pour l'avenir à voir des
spectacles des gros spectacle sens bien
aussi vous écris ce le facebook plate de
son passé de la voix qu'on ne parle d'un
podcast et les commentaires les
commentaires et jori gien désobligeants
les commentaires négatifs par rapport à
son duel que rigoni comptes publics
mais quand on vous rappelle non vous ne
faites pas ça mais les autres d été se
calmer sur les messages un nu mais sinon
scénographe vraiment belles découvertes
belle personne le fait quand même bien
rafa 20 avant que vienne sur le podcast
avant que fasse la voie parce que c'est
aussi une activité gagnent en a parlé on
a parlé un petit peu de deux organismes
dans le podcast
mais c'est avant tout une personne
extrêmement positives puis je son
énergie est contagieuse laitiers - en ce
moment je vais aller courir quand ça
s'est fini puis je vais être dans nos
rangs puisque sourire aux postes qu'ils
aient beaucoup de monde qui sourit aux
passants fait qu'écouter les
segmentations anglais sinon vous êtes
commenté sur youtube abonnez vous à nos
chances que ce soit sur youtube sur l
application balade aux abonnés vos notes
pétrone si vous voulez du conte
exclusive qu'on recommence à faire
bientôt c'est pas l'ami en nommant
piquionne ont vu le jour piscine ont
écouté et fait juste
un casse croûte bon bah de caste
[Musique]
c'est commencer justement un bras c'est
vraiment cool
j'étais vraiment content j'imagine tout
projet ddm commenter en direct de
patente et dans ce que tu lis pas
maintenant mais ddm de monde que tu
connais celui qui est toujours soin qui
veulent te dire good job
oui oui pis je m'installe me tombe le
lendemain de chacune de mes performances
et les gens n'aiment plus parce
qu'évidemment c'est l'eau qui s'inscrit
l'espèce de ddd fait deux phénomènes qui
je m'assois plus je prends la journée au
grand complet j'ai bon oui la journée au
complet pour ce conte à tout le monde
que tu as eu ces autres que se fasse
parce qu'en plus c'est qu'il sait que la
voix mettons contrairement à un chemin
occupation double c'est mon expérience à
moi moi j'ai pas pu ré bon à tout le
monde parce que ça arrive en différé oui
c'est ça sort de l'ops des mets toi
c'est en indirect
mais ça c'est cool que tu prennes matin
répond à tout le moins c'est cool c'est
cool au moins six agents n'avaient pas
trop millions est alors que j'ai su
dealé avec mais c'est rohff parce que tu
passes dans avoir 15 par un mois à 1500
aux orties vraiment intense mais j'ai
vraiment essayé de répondre à tout le
monde des fois c'est difficile c'est
épuisant surtout d'avoir leur corps tout
le temps sur le cellulaire si je me sens
un peu dans ma bulle mais si ce jeu
prend toute la journée du lendemain est
là pour vraiment répondre aux jeunes
enfants plongeante reygadas où est le
message de fond ça serait le demi finale
oui assure la demi finale quand j'ai
gagné contre eric faye annoncé les
grands thèmes du québec un texte à la
can on y est excellent c'est le suicide
enfants ont pu le volet série fx était
quasiment la moitié du monde qui sont un
monde qui ne seraient pas toujours
exactement
c'est du coup c'est pas ces ions lyon
puis je comprends qu'on a chacun une
préférence et toupie beaucoup de gens
découvrent et qui avaient des pages fan
des groupes fans sur facebook prend
vingt mille personnes qui l'inquiète
c'est vrai qu il a commencé sa page sur
facebook sa page fan
comme trois jours après que la voie est
commencé puis je pense que les rendus à
50000 like là c'est le seul qui s'est
rendu à assas son petit moi j'en ai
jamais vu mélopées lorsqu'elles sont
déjà là la base moi je pensais que
j'allais perdre parce que sur facebook
ce thème c'était fou comment les
statistiques qui démontrait que moi j'ai
perdu énormément donc j'étais très
surprise que les gens s'ils étaient
parce que ils y ont vu aussi les
statistiques qui ont vu se sont dits
crime c'est sûr que c'est lui qui gagne
c'est lui qui avait le plus de fans mais
je ne sais pas qu'est ce qui s'est passé
pas nécessairement
non c'est pas un reflet est la copie
mois la finance justement
battez sauvegarder les réseaux sociaux
tu pensais pas que j'allais dire gagner
c'est non c'est pas gagné puis vient le
grenier pisté par ses collègues
mais moi je pas honnêtement les sur
internet andrik cet accord les comme
tout le monde je l'avais dit j'avais
deux corps étaient au courant que tout
le monde crie ton nom le site c'est que
josy c'est quasiment sûr que c'est au
client une pizza il dira mois 1/2 finale
et jetés compte jo depuis tout le monde
écrivait jacques finalement c'est moi
que johnny 66 % et plus je me suis pas
vraiment exactement mais fête d'enfant
peut jamais se fier réel masse puis
c'est aussi une question du momentum
avec la performance je pense que la
performance au plus un plus un lien
qu'on peut penser le monde ils écoutent
puis je sais pas maintenant le monde
sont des femmes
autre livre les votes sont déjà
enregistrés le tyran sans foule mais ça
c'est pas tout le monde qui côtoie le
manque de lavaur salon qui ont coûté la
vôtre la saison qui semble qu'ils disent
moi je vais voter oui qui dit je vais
voter pour la performance qui me fait le
plus exact oui vraiment si ça c'est pas
jouer tant que c'est pas jouer mais
c'est moi ça me fascine le fixie que
vous avez vous avez la réception en
temps réel sur sept ans
c'est vraiment et en sait quelque chose
c'est beau la recevoir sadr est
différent des deux vous qui ce qui est
ressorti plat
je m'aime pas l'entièreté de ce qui a
été dit sur ce jour aucune idée des
dégâts commis 30 et toute une suis vite
les trend à chaque semaine moi j'ai
aucune idée de ce à quoi on parle et la
maison mais tais toi maintenant
justement après après le deuxième tour a
pris les duels tout c'est quoi le monde
parlait le courante et elle est exacte
je sais qu'on m'attende ça fait en sorte
que ça me donne des outils aussi pour
mes prochaines performances quelques
qu'est ce que les gens veulent
maintenant que je posais des questions
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous voulez
mon temps de chanter
quel style de musique tu es je voulais
aussi m'adapter à la demande du public
parce que vraiment je vais pas tomber si
je veux vraiment m'adapter à ce qu'ils
veulent ou s'ils fake toutain je veux
pas me dénaturer non plus mais ça c'est
fait pour ce que si c'était avantageux
de d'y aller de semaine en semaine
voilà c'est quoi l'étape où est ce que
la réaction était la plus forte
c'est définitivement quand j'ai gagné
contre 8 qui c'est à dire parce que bon
évidemment moi je m'en attendais pas les
autres on attend des deux bords qui a eu
beaucoup d'articles qui ont été écrits
comme quoi les gens en général ne
s'attendait pas à ce que je gagne
pis là il ya une grosse réaction parce
qu'évidemment en même temps quand je
suis passé quand j'ai fait mes autres me
et zoug sans l'aveuglent j'ai eu que des
beaux commentaires j'ai eu comme de
trois commentaires de personnes qui
étaient un peu moins moins cool pas
prête pour les autres non c'était pas le
temps car c'est ça exactement le télé
j'en prends pas ça c'est comme si vite
mais pas contre un autre voilà
exactement exactement fait que peu
d'espèces de la compétition préférence
avec sauce était au départ je me suis
dit c'est vraiment possible
le par la suite la prochaine table
salies duel puis mon partenaire jacques
homme s'est fait voler ses clés y avait
personne pour dire à ces personnes
étaient unis donc ça a été un avantage
pour nous si ce qu'on s'est dit hier ça
va être plus douter pour notre ère pour
notre part caution vers l'action est
plus doux pour demain exactement t par
contre j'ai été témoin des gens qui
rient hc fort contre une des
participantes
ariane qui est un équipe derrick qui l a
reçu énormément énormément de haine
pour sa performance en au duel tout le
monde sur un article écrivait que l
aurait pas de gagner qui était pas bonne
ntt europe ça a été une heure le mauvais
sens pour elle c'est là que j'ai réalisé
mon dieu c'est à ce prix que ça arrive
ça arrive encore à ce jour des gens qui
écrivent des méchants commentaires je
comprendrais jamais seul parce que c'est
un opinion qui n'est gars s'il garde la
porte européenne mais zéro construisit
non c'était juste la bâche et la
rabaisser
il y aurait dû gagner tes pieds je dis
souvent que c'est important de nos ports
a baissé un talent sous prétexte qu'on a
préfère un autre train on peut toujours
en lv1 pitt et moi c'est sûr que je
préfèrerais me 7,6 correct et angoisse
pareil mais de dire rater pour aider
pour i saw 6 cd gallas fait que dans le
fond - je me suis dit qui bat g
quand inconsciemment c'est sûr que je me
suis dit que ça pourrait m'arriver à moi
mais quand c'est arrivé à rien je me
jetais concentrer que sur sa situation
puis je dis j'essaie de lui donner le
plus d'amour pionsat comme réuni toute
la voix ensemble puis on a dit on s'est
dit qu'on allait supporter à travers
toutes et tous les obstacles fait quand
on on a quand même on était complet une
simulation qui ont fait des messages
visent à faire comme cela le fait que au
moins tiens t'es pas tout seul adam
c'est là qu'on a réalisé que ça arrive
c'est de la voix ccc particulier pis si
loxam
ça détonne complètement d'occupation
double c'est que c'est un talent que te
quitte à amener la personne qui est là
qui est pas talentueux
oui pis mettons de quelqu'un critiquent
la façon par exemple que moi je tape
arue atterri dans un montage
compréhensif je comprends mais il
critiqué deux pas de critiquer mais de
juste donner du est à quelqu'un qui a
fait une performance artistique du mieux
de ses capacités
ouais ça si elle a gagné il devait avoir
quelque chose que ça leur joint et oui
c'est c'est c'est viscéral jouve cx
érable c'est vicieux puis il a vraiment
beaucoup de nous
avec cette attitude là toujours pas
mieux que de rien faire mais oui c'est
cette offre jugeant que rien fait avec
eux et une personne offre quelque chose
une performance puis ta réaction c'est
que ça met en crise je comprends pas
vraiment parce que quand on performe si
satisfait pas une affaire de montage
vidéo qui peut-être kinky cdd je me suis
mal exprimé sur tal afar 10 piges
comprend ce moment mais c'est vraiment
performance et et on a une minute et
demie pour tout donner et on s'aide
littéralement s'est dénudé pendant
l'étape son maillot sur marie l'état
doivent s'adapter en décalé un peu comme
les boutons rôle qui écoute on s'est
fait des scénarios l'camp qu'internet on
est là parce qu'on veut et à la fin on
t'enlève voilà mais oui on sait on s'est
dénudée manière est fédérée et devant
les gens' cc nous dans tout notre
vulnérabilité puis on s'offre aux aux
gens qui on donne tout ce qu'on est et
textures qui console faits reprochés
d'une manière ou d'une autre c'est
difficile parce que c'est déjà difficile
c'est un stress énorme que de performer
devant les gens souvent à danton jeudi
on a chacun l'on ne manque de confiance
philippe les petites affecté évidemment
personne n'est parfait fait qu on est
tellement déjà exigeant envers anversois
que deux hommes se présenter aux gens
comme ça
qui on reçoit un come back tellement
négatif c'est difficile c'est vraiment
de sicile ouais c'est quoi apparemment
ce qui était le plus fier est une
question séjour mais non eh ben c'est
une très bonne question je pense que la
performance que j'ai fait encore de
finale parce que c'est la performance
qui m'a le plus propulsé les c'est là
que les gens ont vraiment compris
l'essence de mon talent le ton c'est là
qu'ils ont dit ok peut-être qui sait
solo genre c'est sa 4e qui avait
présenté au monde ces puits je pense que
c'est ce qu'ils m'ont amené à à être
plus confiante sur le stage c'est ça qui
fait en sorte que les gens ont compris
ce que je voulais offrir à la voie
puisque je la portais ma direction c'est
exactement ce que je pense et ça mais de
très près les lamas dernières portes
pour commencer j'ai fait ce qui était
tout simplement une performance que j'ai
expliquées de célébration j'ai juste eu
du fun
je pense que c'est ça oui c'est ça j'ai
jamais si tu es juste j'ai ce thème à
mon avis des plus tôt je sais j'ai
bouclé la boucle avec cette performance
la piste est juste comme une m n'a à mon
parcours à la moitié a existé entre
chaque don le choix de chanson à la fin
non j'ai pas hésiter non c'est avec sa
lettre mais ce qui est drôle c'est que
je la connaissais pas du tout je
connaissais les beatles je connaissais
les chais parce que c'est une reprise et
des chansons d'edith oscar espèce de
mash up 2 2 puis au départ j'avais en
tête de chantier de lessines de beyoncé
c'est quelque chose que je voulais à eux
que je voulais faire et parce que c'est
une chanson qui que j'aime énormément
que je chante depuis que je suis tout
jeune pays vocalement aussi cette sas a
montré l'étendue de ma puissance puis je
me suis une bonne idée mais marc qui
m'est arrivé avec cette chanson là puis
a dit écoute subitement ce que tu en
penses puis le fait coûté puis tout de
suite je me suis qui sert il faut que je
fasse on dirait que c'était ceux qui
quittaient le plus le plus avantageux
dans mon parcours l'essonne c'est une
chanson je suppose qu'ils la connaissent
une chanson qui ressort après c'est
comme si je revenais après ce que
j'avais fait encore de finale je voulais
je voulais faire quelque chose de
différent j'avais jamais rien fait pour
ben comme ça
avec un peu plus de betty fait que je me
suis dit c'est vraiment c'est qu'il faut
que je fasse plus en plus le message la
vague de la chanson est vraiment venu me
chercher
ouais fait que puis de toute manière
j'ai fait tellement confiance à marc
il m'a tellement toujours diriger dans
la bonne direction puis une grande
grande partie de la raison pour laquelle
je me suis rendu aussi loin c'est
vraiment lui c'est pas juste mon talent
c'est vraiment la combinaison entre son
expertise à lui puisque moi je savais
offrir pire mais comme fait un match en
pensant qu'ils on était un jour d'en
faire le vraiment puis m'a propulsé le
plus loin qu'ils pouvaient s'écoute moi
j'ai l'impression que marc c'est
vraiment le coach des coaches m'ont
arrêté t comme je disais avant de
commencer ma blonde a fait de la voix et
puis j'ai rencontré un peu gt gt dans la
famille accompagnatrice comme je disais
oui mais tu marques tu sens vraiment
qu'ils y m soit être le mc kenzie
derrien massa qui est honnête c'est ça
qui est bon il faut vraiment y est
excellent impie pige s'est senti
vraiment des costumes que
puis ils font puissent écouler une fois
c'est fini c'est fini
marc après sega mène son monde en
tournée non s'il continue il est
vraiment impliqué oui marc est tellement
élevé 6 j'ai jamais vu quelqu'un d'aussi
investi ces de ses sims des wanna go
leur hymne aux images ils m'ont pris
dans son équipe si je les choisis au
soutien aveugle
puis j'ai dit que j'ai acheté aller avec
la décision du moment puis la balise
moment c'est vrai la veille je loge la
file est de lui mais ça faisait
longtemps que ça me trottait dans la
tête que je voulais être systolique est
loin je savais que si je le savais je
m'affale la vague du moment juste qu'on
fait mais que que c'est avec lui jules
être mais il est investi depuis le début
il m'écrivait sur instagram petit mot
fort louis m'ont écrit sur sa g
lt chansons telles chansons sa tendresse
la fage et il me donne ce numéro on
s'appelle puis comment va ta voix est
vraiment l'opib vickers le genre il se
soucie profondément six candidats et pas
juste de ce candidat souci des autres si
ce qui est vraiment le fond ainsi allé
voir m vincent deh l'équipe d'alex pis
elle commença vote c'est six terroristes
un humain d'exception ce gala il
donnerait tout tout tout tout c'est vrai
que à steam c'est peut- on la voit fini
pied du taraf tu veux je peux être
encore ton coach j'ai dit oui marqué mon
coach pour le reste de ma ville vraiment
très cool oui mais c'est de comment je
t'entends par les [ __ ] en tout on
dirait que cet entretien pod
sentiment négatif par rapport à toute
l'expérience aucun aucun succès ces
foules
c'est ce qui est beau c'est vraiment
beau or que tu entends sud c'est souvent
des grosses productions comme ça parce
que souvent souvent t il ya le facteur
monétaire le facteur d'argent qui fait
que l'être humain derrière les candidats
que ce soit dans des sous dans des gros
shows comme aux dés dans des annonces
chocs comme la voix qui sous tendent à
faire de même
souvent les candidats prennent un peu le
bol en termes d'éthique et en termes de
respect de l'être humain
une expérience qui m'apparaît comme
comme impeccable absolument non vraiment
ce qui est très cool à dire en ce moment
pour le voile
ben oui exactement non ça a été une
expérience exceptionnelle de a à z
littéralement mais c'est parce que j'ai
pas personnellement j'ai papillon
rentrerai pas dans les détails mais j'ai
pas eu des bons commentaires
particulièrement de d'autres candidats -
à 20 qui juste parce que la production
était différente le concept voilà oui
exactement
la peau est pas avare non plus leur
expérience à l'aimer ce que peut-être
que le certaines critiques
encore une fois l'équipe a changé je
sais pas exactement mais moi je trouve
quand même que la voix ce qui est le fun
c'est qu'ils y mettent l'emphase comme
une diversité de voix de talent de ce
type c'est l'fun pis ils dénaturent
porte et non comme à blondel tarby a dit
mouche est elle celle de musique mais ce
jeu phare cool parfait on y arrive
poussée pas exactement ce que ton style
ils vont tendre temps trouver un
mais ce qu'ils font ce type de voix face
aux pies n'est pas gagné d'avancé pour
n'importe quel style non plus exactement
à ces sas essayons pour l'instant est
d'aider les prix requis qu'il faut que
ce soit comme ça puis comme si pour
gagner la voir en particulier de ces ou
pour se frayer un chemin dans la
compétition fait que ça c'est vraiment
le fun puis aussi c'est ça comme tu dis
dénature pas ce que tu es réellement t
it offre ict offre des options mais en
bout de compte dans mon année à moi
ils lui ont toujours été vraiment
extrêmement les côtés avec ça dans le
fond c'est possible comme que les
expériences d'avant dans les années
précédentes était mauvais c'est juste
que c'était complètement différent
puis moi de ce que j'ai vécu c'est que
ion et ion prioriser cette année les
producteurs qui ont été absolument
exceptionnelle ils y ont priorisé
l'humain avant tout donc c'était pommes
maison moi je disais j'arrivais encore
de finale en demi finale je disais moi
c'est pas cette chanson le jeu phare
flamand je me sens pas bien la fin puis
on l'avait déjà pratiqué avec la belle
on l'avait enregistrée sur le quai de
l'hôtel puis je m'attendais à ce qu'on
me dise le raf le théâtre de dernière
minute puis c'est comme désolé mais sauf
lorsqu'on ce qu'on dit de faire puis mon
à simon du raf la chose continue qui
nous tient le plus à coeur c'est ton
bonheur si nos candidats sont power '
nous on n'a pas bien fait notre job
temps changent et je suis vraiment
s'arrêter un peu fait que changer de
thoune a donné un second dernière
seconde oui c'était fou rire au début
c'était pas faut faire de quoi booster
je t'aime de lara fabian
ok oui c'est pas parce que j'ai j'adore
la chanson si c'est un classique mais y
avait plusieurs facteurs qui faisait en
sorte que c'était pas la chanson je
voulais performer c'était cette journée
là j'avais fait prime aux quarts de
finale avant qui est une chanson qui
démonte qui se déploie à la fin mais
j'ai peur j'ai cru qu'ils mentent
c'est en termes de chanteuse on parle de
baird puis c'était ce je t'aime c'est
sauter tout le long c'est vraiment du
betting c'est vraiment comme la tnt puis
je voulais y aller dans quelque chose
d'un petit peu plus un terrain un peu
plus sensible plus doux puis si cette
chanson là me l'offrait pas
particulièrement puis aussi j'avais de
la misère à me me l'approprier parce que
je devais c'est lara fabian
comment faire une chance un tas 6 devant
moi et comment comment rendre une
chanson aussi bien sinon meilleur que la
race est impossible dans ma tête c'est
l'été c'est impossible pitt d'autant
plus qu était littéralement en face de
moi je me suis dit est-ce que tu
avantageux je pense pas je vais y aller
avec quelque chose que je peux je peux
remodelé à magna ce que je voulais pas
dénaturer non plus du tout cette chanson
le qui lui appartient picallo déjà fait
à la perfection à 100%
donc voilà c'est la raison pour laquelle
j'ai pas fait j'étais mais on l'avait
déjà pris un ton on l'avait déjà tout
inscrit parce qu'on a enregisté chanson
prix à l'import 6% sous les pieds pour
le band qui ayant fait acquis graf cité
pas heureuse on va changer sauter ils
ont vraiment été exceptionnelle j'ai eu
aucun aucun j'ai aucune aucun mouvement
mauvais souvenir et yahoo aucun drame
autant de candidats que les personnes
qui travaillaient en triangle comme je
dis on priorise est tout le temps
l'humain c'est exceptionnel j'ai
vraiment eu le temps de répéter la tonne
gg oui parce qu'on l'a choisi la non
j'ai le temps de répéter parce qu'on
répète tout le temps au studio avec les
musiciens comme isolant régis pour
constater qu'après puis le stelle matin
que j'avais fait je t'aime le matin puis
par la suite ils m'ont laissé comme
rester au studio puis on aurait fait la
chanson faux film après avec est cool
avec sa belle bowling mais marco était
vraiment les coupes c'est marc effet
leur rafraîchir aux producteurs
je veux pas je pars gossé qui ont
tellement une grosse charge sur les
épaules mais il ya un fait grave c'est
tellement correct c'est fou ce que
faisait capoter qu'en cash capable on le
faisait que je voyais ça allait c'est
puis moi est un musicien je sais c'est
quoi que sa demande comme travail et
méthodes et justement ça qui va changer
de tenue et les tonalités trois fois
puis à qui ils matière d'éthique la
chorale le soir les affaires de mon
petit enzo typhon sur tout le temps mais
qui dit cathy candidate vos compotes
rosso aller tout seul chez asus mouthe
mais il dortmund qui pédalent en est en
arrière fonctionne pas évidemment
justement ma blonde c'est ça c'était
comme 15 h 40 hier finalement non kiflam
en fait ce puits c'est comme ça ça
change cinq fois dans journée plus le
soir si le shopi son larcin c'est exact
non non c'est capoter à od y avait notre
notre nounou qui avait travaillé sur
star académie c'est que lui était comme
assistant technique sur star academy
pizza daniel bélanger a fait une
performance a amené c'était l'année de
jean-marc performance comme le matin est
arrivé avec plus exactement de
l'histoire mais disait comme ils
voulaient installer des trucs sur le
plafond mais il seul matin une autre cha
cha ca malade qu'est genre des rails
face telles affaires le geer soit en
appelant sensibiliser comme guillemot
flottille ont besoin de fabriquer rails
pour mettre au plafond d'assez danièle
hervieu c'est assure le show c'est comme
tabarnak les pandas ça va mène avec deux
autres assistants techniques sans vos
pierres et les trucs plus qu'à me daniel
bélanger l'uqam dernier arrive le soin
aux pieds des rails au plafond mais ça
c'est pas ma qui sera même pas convaincu
d'avoir eu toute la journée était
profond de la loge à quatre pattes en
train de vomir
tant qu'emblème avait visé c'est exact
c'est fou on se rend pas compte à quel
point l'équipe technique travaille
d'arrache-pied les musiciens c'est moi
ma chanson que j'ai fait en finale
est ce qu'on l'a dessin on l'a descendue
en même temps qu'ils ont les seuils tout
le monde
l'ailier pascal moi j'avais comme des
places j'avais des violons des coptes
qui ont toute décence de même temps on
l'a finalement non la fed attend plus on
est pauvre il joue au plus près dans les
rêves la majorité son parcours à
l'aveuglé gonnard ya eu pas mal à l'ipad
la météo live c'est comme que tous les
musiciens font partie du show ben oui
après tony parker exacte des charges en
plus de faux tonalité exact c'est
impossible pour ceux que ça fait que ça
représente
c'est rohff le caylar français da jobs
n'était pas de faire sans excellent un
homme ayant été affiné son terme en fin
d'émission était tellement ils sont à
l'écouté supporte ok raf est ce que tu
préfères si tu préfères ce dans
l'arrangement t comme j j'avais mon mot
à dire constamment
c'est vraiment un gros gros gros respect
mutuel qui avait entre nous dans toute
l'équipe c'est vraiment ma famille ouais
la digue s'est vraiment côte
la bisbille existe aussi des sceptiques
et qui c'est qui c'est michel est en
baisse car l'attaquant david laflèche
egibar le lui lui
ses inspirations triste et incroyable
puis en tant qu'humain il est tellement
extraordinaire il vraiment vraiment
vraiment profondément gentil pied y est
tellement professionnel pire non pour
régis geste exceptionnel au pied gilbert
aussi qui lui doit la batterie ou
séquences et tous les effets il fait
comme il fait aussi le camp souvent
quand on avait des paulin c'est
excellent et on oublie que ce malavoy
qui est en berne pas ça sonne comme un
album c'est moi je les écoute toujours à
j'écoute la benne autant que tu écoutes
le cas parce que c'est vraiment bon
c'est parfait c'est que si tu as ma part
fait remarquer la présence un playback
c'est tout la banque sont comme ça moi
ça n'a aucun sens c'est moi faufilons là
il y en avait peut-être deux heures
entre et la fois que j'ai fait j'ai
terme puis finalement on enregistrait
faufile après ces mêmes postes est même
pas deux arrêtés où ils y ont eu leur
pause puis on travaille d'autres
candidats je pense qu'ils ne pensaient
qu'à l'écouter ou quoi c'est fou c'est
faux je comprends posséder gemin
vraiment tout le monde sur le plateau
sont des génies je pense qu'avec un
ballon le feu samedi qui avait un gars
qui étaient chez eux qui lui faisait
litscher permettant que charles est une
halte et david rambeau malarchuk tel
taux ou à échanges tal afar avec les
effets du wacken pack du progrès qui a
appelé le groupe sophie envoyée mais ça
prend du monde du travail rapidement
genre de production là parce qu'on sait
jamais qu est ce qui a résulté surtout
des live ça représente travail à sa
juste le côté technique le nom à hawaï
et georges piel manque à meyreuil a
tellement d'éclairage et de leçon pour
tout le monde crypte le dernier
lancement des 24 candidats sont des
micro tout les kits ont dit comment
comment gérer ça et pourtant ils nous
ont géré au corps de tous était écouté
on était vraiment vraiment n'était pas
laissée seule à nous même si on savait
exactement où s'en aller quand ils ont
vraiment bien fait seuls vraiment
vraiment cessé car en effet attendre que
mercy avant la fin de la journée que les
journées total avec ses cd l'enl en
tournage au sol avec je peux pas oui
que dalle tant que maman ça va finir de
3 ce matin puis une fois les bennes
avait averti ouais faut des corps face
lady marmelade personnes jour n'est pas
vraiment ça pour eux c'est une scène
j'ai une stalactite avec patrick bruel
en parler avait raconté que bon la star
academy il fallait comme s'adapter
vraiment ou de manque depuis ce qui ce
qui est drôle c'est que à chaque fois
qu'il y avait un artiste on faisait des
médias avec les artistes qui de nous
avec notre coach vocal qui est
absolument extraordinaire marie-eve
riverains est la meilleure et on
s'assoyait pile à nous donner nos voix
qui on faisait piste et un médecin je
sais pas combien de temps quoi jean sept
minutes le temps puis c'est plusieurs
chansons du même artiste l'on va parler
de patrick ses besoins chanson de
patrick puis on s'adapte et puis le y
avait une chorégraphie plus il fallait
se placer de telle manière qu toupie lui
arrive qu'il lui avait pour garder tu
sais quoi parce qu'ils avaient peur reçu
où il y avait pas le temps d'essayer un
show ils se parent occupé cet homme là
c'est fou puis donc était comme ça
s'peut énormément qu'il y ait beaucoup
de choses qui changent fait qu
évidemment il ya eu des choses qui ont
changé les harmonies qui ont été
différentes
puis y'a vraiment fallu s'adapter puis
on met à me tourner était sur le plateau
puis on avait tout placer les caméras
puis on avait placé le piano puis nous
ça fait longtemps qu'on atteint 181
mbaye parce que c'est long c'est
évidemment des pratiques qu'il a dit est
non c'est pas mon bon côté fait qu'il
faut tout changer fait que ça a pris une
heure voilà ça tout le temps été c'est
vraiment une question d'adaptation le
foot lui voulait passer comme si vous
laisser comme ça puis tu est ce correct
parce qu'évidemment qu'on aille vite
parce qu'on a un respect incroyable pour
cette personne ne dit évidemment on veut
répondre à tous à toutes ces demandes si
c'est bien important
tout l'argent le sexe et patrick c'était
passant beaucoup travaillé avec les c1
contre amazon vraiment vraiment que tu
tombes ouais bah j'avais demandé au ft
qui t'ont ces microbes des écoutes et
j'étais intriguée j'ai tellement tripé
avec isabelle boulay qui était une
personne absolument extraordinaire
tellement chaleureuse tellement
l'écoutent qui donne des conseils à
s'exprime de manière impeccable dans les
conseils qui m'ont énormément aidé qui
ont été tellement précieux à mon
parcours puis à ma chanson que j'ai fait
en demi finale mais mon gros gros coup
de coeur ça a vraiment été macro
bretonne qui enchante avec nous en
finale parce que je connais ses chansons
mais il fait pas partie mais il fait pas
partie de mon parcours musical quand
j'étais jeune c'est moi c'est mes
parents qui ont six mois devrait
comporter j'écoutais tout le temps tu es
ont très peu ses chansons et tout mais
quand il ya pénétré dans la pièce où on
était quand pratiquer il ya une énergie
en lutte anti y est tellement c'est un
grain c'est vraiment regretté fait quand
il rentrait puis s'est mis à chanter ya
poussé la première note qu' on se dit et
qu'il donne certain âge contact qui va
pas chanter comme chantait bas-canada ce
nom il chante pareil aucun sens
il pose sa première note on se met tout
à broyer david laflèche pleure je
m'excuse avec davy pleure je pleure
quand on y pleure tout le monde pleure
toulon était au rwanda pas
par son talent il ya vraiment quelque
chose de spécial avec ça a été difficile
en pratique de chanter avec lui on
personnes sortaient des notes on était
tout en train de broyer comme des vieux
cons vraiment c'est vraiment c'était
vraiment fou comme expérience pillent de
juste chanter à côté d'un grand comme ça
et puis qui mec mais partager toutes
sont tous sont alain puis on espère que
son expertise aussi pu me donner des
bons mon pays que le temps parle avec
les gilts en parler avec moi qui
coordonne le temps avec je sais pas pour
les autres mais je sais qu'on a eu une
belle conversation avec lui et juste
avant de rentrer sur scène pieds
tellement humain ségolène est tellement
drôle d'oeil aux petits y était super
statique
quand il a chanté mais ceci simplement
parce qu'il conserve son énergie lui
pour lui chanter c'est rien c'est les
douze donnes en l espèce des notes
sparrow pis y'a pas de problème là
exposé des spartiates x et son style
mais autrement il est en vrai du mali
par chaleureux il est tellement gentil
avec moi j'ai vraiment connecté avec lux
aeterna un honneur immense de partager
la scène avec lui toute ma vie toute ma
vie s'est imprégné en moins là de cette
sensation l'okimo qui m'a donné la wii
fou ce qu'ils vous ont dit ce qu'ils ont
donné une version de toutes les
performances que vous avez fait non ils
ne vont pas donner ça je pense qu'on
pourrait le demander non mais je sais
pas si on a accès à sa médecine nos
performances sont sur youtube qui sont
sur le site mais le pôle aventure au
grand complet fait que moi j'aurais
voulu voit enfin moi j'ai enregistré sur
mater litige achetez-le comme jean deux
jours avant parce que j'avais pas rater
la vente et je me suis fort improbable
je me regarde maman mais je sais pas si
on axait faudrait que je demande c'est
vraiment l'fun de garder son sommet mais
oui je sais que même sur youtube je sais
pas si c'est encore cela mais l'année
passée
ebay qui publie quelque chose sur
youtube un an après l'enlève c'est fait
maintenant les quarts de finale de cette
année ils ont enlevé les quarts de
finale de l'année passée surtout fait qd
il faut vraiment qu'ils enregistrent
dans tes affaires à terre puis est ce
que toutes les paires force on le passe
temps pour ça non pas s'il en est qui y
en a qui a pas les droits fait qu'il y
avait les droits de l'homme de la paire
formée n'y avait pas les doigts de la
main sur youtube c'est des fois puis en
quête des foyers il pouvait juste pour
la fin de course et contexte comment ça
fonctionne c'est les droits de chansons
sur youtube et quand j'ai vu sur ma
chaîne youtube sans fait le podcast que
cech et des vidéos pour les droits
d'auteur de chansons sur youtube les cas
c'est pas moi qui ai cherché ce pas
caresser youtube je crois ouais je pense
que oui je pense que c'est comme ça que
ça fonctionne ils peuvent tout à enlever
je sais ponge pourri avec ce fait pour
c'est à ma peau me demander ça - j'ai
aucune idée mais je sais que c'est mais
c'est un peu des avantages aussi ce qui
c'est ça qui est plate le ton jeu mon
ami stéphane qui lui a chanté une
chanson
sa chanson hajoubi nombre de ces normes
et chansons brillantes que brest est
entendu un lot sans l'aveuglent ben oui
elle a été publiée sur youtube morizet
avant lé drame les grands majors deux
mois après avec lui en termes de view
spyder reach évidemment il était
derrière tous les autres
balsillie a pas le choix il y en a ça
perfo ça a été son soutien aveugle qui
était christine love de beyoncé avec les
loges qui avaient pas les droits avec la
seule version qui est sur youtube c'est
quelqu'un qui fait la qualité comme on
dit je veux d'emballer bourse
ouais c'est nommé chanson préférée au
monde c'est mal à encaisser ces peuples
c'est tellement coutts est une version
12 pouces alors de version une version
dans le petit temps mais avec et avec
une intro avec en fond une fenêtre ou
bien sûr fait live c'est comme un petit
but de love on top
oui je sais c'est quoi ça à skis à ecône
c'est malin que j'arrive ans était à 6
et puis c'est aussi en avance un peu
jusqu'à dimanche cette semaine à fond
oui finalement comment ça s'est passé
pour toi cette journée-là à cette
journée locke mettant les 48 heures
jusqu'à aujourd'hui
ouais le dimanche on est tous vraiment
très épuisés parce que ce qu'on ce qu'on
ne sait pas de ce parcours leur mais
peut-être que vous en doutez c'est que
le ton le dimanche c'est live mais
puisque c'est live toutes les répètes se
font les jours d'avancé fait nous poser
douze heures dans les locaux ont même
style à attendre pilote stand-by plus
affalo performance pire avant tout
ben non je revenais pas chez nous si
j'habite juste à côté du four mais
heureusement la petite mon était un
hôtel parce qu'il sait il y en a
beaucoup qui viennent à québec mais
c'est et moi ça a été c'est beaucoup
plus facile pour moi parce que j'habite
à côté fait que je reviens chez moi je
reviens dans madame à raison chez nous
il ya beaucoup de monde qui était un peu
des îles santa des racines et une chez
the rooms et qu'importe ils viennent
est de l'île aux coudres ça fait deux
semaines qui sont pas chez eux
joe exemple ces infections fait qu'on
est tous émotionnellement et
physiquement très fatiguée pdt notre
voix aussi fait qu'il faut tout le temps
regarder et se coucher pas trop tôt mais
en même temps on termine l'on pratique à
11 heures puis le lendemain 7 à 8 et ça
c'est vraiment difficile mais la prod a
été hyper compréhensive donné beaucoup
de temps pour relaxer pu nous donner des
trucs paix des médicaments sont avait
mal à gauche tout fait que on le
dimanche le dimanche qui viennent passer
pour la finale j'étais épuisé comme tout
ce qui s'est énormément de charge
émotionnelle sur les épaules c'est
beaucoup de pression c'est sûr je suis
100% reconnaissante de ce qui m'arrive
mais si c'est beaucoup on se le cachera
pas pisser norme c'est qu'ils ont tous
puis surtout qu'à la base moi je
jetterai pas sur l'aspect compétition
fait que sable ça ça me stresse
énormément de savoir qu'il regagne enfin
perdant puis déjà que j'avais eu un come
back dans les demi-finales qui était
difficile qui fait en sorte que je je
dois vous m'enlevez un peu des réseaux
sociaux parce que c'était blessant pour
moi je me tiens je te survivrai vraiment
c'est un mouton que je gagne moi dans ma
thèse c'est ceci mettons que je gagne
c'est ce qu'il me dit tu vas pas de
mouvement pas de conscience qu'on était
quatre classes tapageuse 2 le stade iv
il y avait trois autres personnes de
vivre avec ce standing pis comme si on
était fatigué au cours de la journée en
ton travail puis on est tout le temps
sur la gaule en sambre au maquillage
qu'on a une technique exceptionnelle de
maquillage confort et style est conservé
au maquillage présente en ferrain et
plus on s'envoie des références en
pratique et plus on monte une fort côté
de feu peloter fait que c'est vraiment
étant ce qu on est tout le temps à nos
appels le temps de manger
fake rendu le à la fin j'étais comme une
quiche épuisé tige
on savait que ça me tombe aussi je
gagnais la personne dernier le geneviève
c'est ce qu'elle a dû faire le lendemain
à se lever à 4 heures marie bové salut
bonjour pleine tournée la tournée des
entrevues t c est plus ample laventure
ça ne s'arrêtait pas l'hôte et en finale
pourrait être ça continue ses pieds on
s'est tous dit
c'est tellement une belle opportunité
puissant gang on va être vraiment hyper
content mais c'est
c'est épuisant s'est fait qu on était on
était tous dans le même ring que c'était
ben correct qu'on donne pas un dit que
ça allait faire du bien aux six amis ont
respecté c'était quasiment ça aussi
c'est clair après odile ça faisait
tellement longtemps qu'on savait que sim
et ont regagné y avait encore deux jours
qu'on n'avait pas accès à nos femmes est
annoncée à la safer le xacti deux jours
sur la grosse patate c'est tellement
rien mais tu t'es rendu au point où est
ce qu'ils essaient de jours c'est
exactement ça c'est pas bien comment
oublier ce triste et quest un
contre-discours 50000 d'euros c'est
quand même considérable pour une journée
plus de secret pour moi ça le fallait
pourtant c'est pas tout ça mais plutôt
comment qui j'étais tanné de l' aventure
mais je commence mon dieu et issam ça me
ferait du bien je respire et enfin toi
ta réaction que j'allais me goni tout
avait l'air
juste contente vraiment nettement
contente oui ça paraissait tvt ont
vraiment spontanément oui c'est de la
joie
c'était vraiment la joie a accueilli
pour une panoplie de raisons
premièrement évidemment pour geneviève
parce que la connaissance ayant appris à
la connaître
puis je pense qu'il y avait un consensus
dans tous les autres finalistes à dire
vincent collet n'est moi qu'on s'en
était parlé on était d'accord pour se
dire que je pensais que c est l dans le
contexte dans lequel on était placée qui
m'effraie le plus de gagny peau qui
méritait par peur par son talent parce
qu'évidemment ça se compare pas des
talents pis c'est tellement relatif mais
qui met retenant dans sa situation
psychique c'est son cri du coeur de
comme chez encore l'hôpital eu des
choses a des choses à apporter au québec
puis le québec l'aiment beaucoup à le
chanter en français ce qui était
avantageux pour rien mais ce qui était
la bonne chose à faire puis c'est
vraiment quelqu'un qui vont rejoindre
les québécois profondément je pense que
c'est la raison pour laquelle aig à lui
gagné de tenter charles ix odyssée série
ce potentiel la ligue 1 47% 5 à 6 cette
foule exactement trois enfants a le
besoin cet argent le nous on est correct
et fait qu'on était quand j'ai appris
c'est geneviève j'étais profondément
hugo boss pour réelles elles le méritent
tellement qui j'étais heureuse pour nous
si les candidats de l'autre côté qui
nous étions dit moi je me suis dit est
ce que je suis vraiment prête à vivre
sauter je savais pas que j'avais des
doutes je savais que j'aime bien vu elle
était prête avec sobriété prête à à
parce que moi je suis très très très
sensible puis c'est quoi et j'ai besoin
que des gens me jean rt parce que je
suis vraiment pourri avec tous les
affamés et l'argent puis les réseaux
puis voilà british pas bonnes avec sa
fille mais je me suis dit est ce qu est
ce que je serai prête à à vivre ce genre
d'affaires le puits à une pomme
dénaturer puis à pau me laisser emporter
dans cette tour bien là sur ce tour bien
tourbillon elle je sais qu est tellement
grande diversité maersk a vu ce caveau
est rendu leur ont tendu l'autre ex pour
ce que j'étais vraiment content pour
elle quand même tu sais quand même ce
faut être prêt à embarquer dans la
machine
le tigre est l'album qui avec l'exode
qui que dans le temps que c'était cinq
ans musique et mes scores exactement
pays et génèrent elle a déjà trois
albums si je m'abuse moins affectés à
ces six kwarasey quoi puis a le vécu
toute assez c'est quoi la l'industrie la
musique qui nous on est des petits
jeunes qui ne savons pas vexer bien et
je pense qu'elle a aussi un style puis
apparemment répertoire qui va vraiment
bien futé avec en place sur les vols au
public et qui veut que tous va rejoindre
exactement c'est parfait pour elle c'est
vraiment la perfection pis c'est la plus
belle chose qui aurait pu nous arriver
puis comme je dis depuis le début je
fais tellement confiance à la vie que à
la fin si j'ai même pas demander aux
gens de voter j'ai juste gg peut rien
soutirer des gens je me suis dit je vais
faire confiance puisse si je sais qu'il
va se passer ce qui fait qu'un il rien
qui arrive pour rien j'ai pour mon dire
c'est que tel mais on se tait on le sait
le fait que je me suis dit je vaux je
peux chercher plus loin à savoir
pourquoi j'ai pas gagné j'ai pas gagné
parce que j'étais pas c'était pas ceux
qui qui qui mettait du à ce moment ci
est dans ma ville parce que c'est une
fois que si tu gagnes
tu sais qu est ce que tu fais pour la
prochaine année c'est oui exactement
le toit temps un peu carte blanche lui
exactement je sais pas c'est quoi les
modalités de votre contrat mais j'ai
l'impression que beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus que si j'avais si j'avais gagné je
suis encore ce contre tous mais sont
tellement petits comme je dis c'est
tellement le fun sont allés coûte
l'avocat est génial on ne le vivez vous
nous parler qui vient qui m'est confiée
à s'occupe du liban puis ils ont été
supers les coulisses par gentil fake
j'ai l'impression que ça va être un lieu
non exactement je me sens pas en cage et
je me sens respirer une personne qui à
la base a besoin d'énormément de liberté
choix comme ça tu puis je me sens pas
comme si on empêchait de faire quelque
chose mais tout fait ou on me dirigeais
de force sous verre quelque chose
puisque je trouve génial
et en plus j'ai la chance d'être avec
mark puis que marc qui reste mon coach
m'a pris la voie t il me prend sous son
aile pindi raf
je vais toujours te montrer
ta valeur puis je veux que tu le
respectes tu as toujours être là pour te
dire qu'est ce que tu fais ce que tu
veux qu'est-ce que tu devrais faire en
toute connaissance de cause parce
qu'évidemment lui dire d'expérience
derrière son chat potté marque
cette semaine j'ai des shows avec lui à
rimouski baguette non forêt rimouski et
gaspé oui victime est un bijou je pars
avec quick aussi parce que c'est ça qui
a pris sous son aile
énormément puis on ne se cachera pas
vrai moi et ya eu énormément de les gens
qui nous aiment entendu nous m c'est
évidemment séparément qu'ils ont chacun
leurs préférences sait bien qu'avec un
somme il ya beaucoup de gens qui nous
associant à la voiture on a fait
beaucoup
jeudi on a appris à se connaître très
rapidement au début de la voix puissante
cliquer en tant qu'humain fait que l'on
était folle proches dont elle fut l'amie
puis en tant qu'artiste si on connecte
musicalement quand on chante qu'on
écoute la musique si on aime le même
genre de choses fait que c'est juste ça
allait de soi qu'on commence à chanter
ensemble les gens aiment ce piard
demande si ce fait si fait un album
ensemble des faits quand on peut pas ne
pas leur donner d'autant plus que nous
sommes ou avantages c'est parce qu'on
aime ça parce que non ça existe
tabarnak si lui même y chasser
rémi chassé moi j'écoute n'ont pas fait
gagner
exact c'est enfin le state
ben oui il fait c'est déjà aussi l'oeil
avec un fanboy soir et que les gens qui
aiment et finest également énormément
heureux qu'il ait été à la fois c'est
comme qui faisait un combat qui avait
comme impur c'était un peu mort panneaux
ce texte faisait longtemps du boudoir
c'est tellement bon ça balance apportant
ce mets y est encore ce parent proche de
des membres du band dans le fond c'est
juste qu'il y avait besoin d'un souffle
de renouveau tous et que c'est la raison
pour laquelle ça termine logistique et
le wiki un nouveau projet qui s'appelle
1 2 3 4 5 avec son ami william qui vont
être in cei m'a fait quitter détour ce
gala est vouée au succès comme j'ai
jamais vu quelqu'un devos comment
pourrais-je ai jamais vu quelqu'un
d'aussi talentueux et rockstar que lui
ivo tout cas c'est là c'est moi
mentalement n'était pas trop là en fait
là ses côtés
je sais qu'à la base le mojo je sais pas
moi perdre je suis vraiment perdu
d'envié mais papa des moniales marston
non non c'est plus que juste je ne sais
pas si tu es comme j'ai besoin de me
demande qui me posent pikine qui me gêne
un peu pour parce que je suis ado parce
que je connais pas du tout l'industrie
piste un peu en toute connaissance de
cause je capable de filer les gens mais
je peux naïve aussi fait que je sais pas
ou mal était fait que parce que je
voudrais que j'ai l'impression que tout
le monde a des bonnes affaires seront
contraintes dans l'industrie ce pas
toujours simple défaut on devient un peu
un objet des fake bref des produits
oui c'est ça moi je sais pas me dirige
étaient mes marques mais prend sous son
aile comme j'ai déjà dit pis je sais
qu'on va les lui je sais c'est que ce
qui va à l'école pour sa critique
dirigée
j'ai une tonne non c'est un plus à ce qu
ils sachent polycom inquiéter moi je
joue toutefois apportés par marthe et
c'est ces pauvres hères c'est mon
deuxième billet il va primer 5 10 c'est
mon deuxième papa ton phrase mon frère
m'a créé mon frère l'a dit mais j'aime
tellement c'est vraiment comme un frère
pour moi il me diriger il montre ils
montrent la voie la rue c'est tout un
conte sa main que ça va tout le temps
passé par le plomb valait oui c'est
comme feeling le reste eh oui c'est
vraiment ce pionner des amis gens
profondément des amis on s'appelle pour
se demander comment ça vaut c'est pas
juste des mots justes muscat luz pas
juste et business ne sait vraiment
commun et comment tu fais aujourd'hui
tiens c'est vraiment se fait que sur ce
magnifique en relation ces cinq qui bref
on veut aller dans son sillon voitures
des chansons ensemble
moi j'ai des chansons qui sont déjà
écrites mais justement exigeante le
syndrome des dés
l'écrivain les jeunes de la mare à dire
que c'est fini tu assez bon avec moi
j'ai simplement lui justin vachon a
confirmé que seuls les nouveaux me dire
à qui on pourrait peut-être ajouter 6
pour modifie peu qu on aille chercher
encore plus de potentiel c'est fait je
sais que là on va focus et sur mon
matériel original mélange la partie
entoure avec la voix expérience jeux wii
faction geste il était rempli pts août
puis après l'été après les tournées je
pense que le jeu va plus me concentrer
sur mon matériel original puisque je
vais faire si jamais ça va peut-être un
pays un album quelque chose comme ça
mais est-il de la direction de la langue
même si sale affaire parce qu'il est je
parle à alicia mémo fait en pensant bien
puis à elle à l'eau à lebouc projets
musicaux qui sont absolument
exceptionnelle puis on est un peu dans
la même vibe elle aussi à ces - français
sont en force et avec moi c'est plus
anglais puis je veux suivre un peu son
sa direction saint pierre sont
faussement et les puits a fait des
affaires comme ça le parallèle avec moi
parce que mon sich plus dans cette vibe
l'ofj va plus aller aux etats-unis c'est
plus que c'est plus qui vient me
chercher chez - qui est bon français
français je vous aime tellement
mais si juste passé - mois puis quand
j'écris j'ai le réflexe d'écrire en
anglais je suis bilingue à la board feec
d'enfants pour moi c'est que naturel de
prendre cette direction le fixie plus
vers leur journal et puis de toute
manière au mot souvent écrit que ou ja
parthenay c'était peut-être moins au
québec et plus aux etats-unis beaucoup
de gens qui sont fans de la voie qu'ils
ont gardé ceux qui ont regardé mon
parcours qui me dit à quito qui m'ont
dit poids je pense que tu devrais plus
se diriger vers la musique et écoute
mettant maintenant si je parle de délits
anna m'a coupé d'encore witt et on est
sortis de thorne et si le fabricant
français au québec on retire on va
essayer de faire de quoi de pop mais de
bon en français ont essayé en essayant
de ses efforts oui pire
je dis pas que c'est impossible mais
nous on n'est jamais arrivé quelque
chose c'est compliqué qui kiffent il est
naturel qu'ils voulaient bien ballon de
ces bilingue et élever sa mère est
anglophone sont pas francophones a le
réflexe des français on va arrêter de se
battre contre ton édition la nature
enfin oui secteur pourrait elle
exactement sauf ses fonctions facile vos
poches madix et lyon d'après eric jamais
exactement ceux de toute manière si je
m'en fous simon si j'ai trop aux
personnes qui me suivent arabe
c'est je veux je veux je veux rester
propre à moi même je peux je veux que ça
reste un instinctif de pommes dénaturer
les symboles de [ __ ] en soit un million
mais en confiance et oui c'est ce je
vais pas si pauvre et que je vais avoir
du succès dans quelque chose si c'est
pas quelque chose qui est proche de -
type ça sert toujours rester comme ça
fait que je m'en fous si je fais ma
musique qui a toujours personne si kim m
ces trois personnes vont tomber sur la
soummam à une fréquence c'est tout ce
qui compte c'est juste que je veux
d'enfants tout d'abord parce que trop
[Rires]
compris mes marques
il me dit venez créé en français puis
marc liaud cette capacité-là de façonner
des tons en français comme si ce n'est
en anglais y est dans sa logique et
autres fous le chef du refrain c'est les
chefs ya aucun j'ai même des refrains
catchy lé j'ai jamais entendu de
l'afrique hachey comme les siennes n'ont
pas vraiment pilule
il est fou ni fou c'est un fou fou il
s'assoit la danse on y prend sa guitare
quand sa guide que le en deux secondes
comment pas avec un affable il ya sept
courage en plein il enregistre son
soutien son iphone là ça devient vite
une spéciale à ces foules mais tonton
départ il a écrit ses chansons qui a
fait les palmarès est tout il l'a écrite
a comme 30 minutes là c'était fini il
est allé la brique orbite à titre semi
ça a été un énorme succès pour vrai
c'est un génie musical il peut tout
faire ce que le ca aucun sens fait que
je sais qu'il y ait la capacité de
cesser de faire sonner des chansons en
français comme si elle était en anglais
fait que ça
c'est le meilleur des deux mondes fera
les 2 ou c# sql ou c'est cela le cette
capacité ouais exact c'est un français
sont hostiles
c'est maintenant la pop comme on la
connaît plus tendue vers l'anglais
charles cardin son style se porte bien à
la langue française
il ya un côté pas mais un quotidien qui
fait que ça va bien aussi fac et si
toute la france est si souvent plus des
balades module un peu son truc pas la
voilà la quitte pas le choix parce que
justement on fait des sauts laissé
d'écrit détonnant français avec la
blonde il va pas vraiment de référence
francophone on a zéro
on essaie de trouver qui est des trucs
de compresses inspiré tiki que réussi à
faire ce qui est bon oui on trouve
vraiment bautista à l'époque mettons de
l'avant à 2015 factice avec dans la
réalisation de la fin des liens c'est
bon ok puisse aimer ton ce kit est
autant français georges travail mais si
oui
comme en plus parler vraiment mais le tu
vois mettons récemment de quoi en
français pop qui sonne américain qui
tant français que je trouve incroyable
c'est angèle hamon veut tellement se
sait comme elle à la russie afin de
vraiment je suis seulement la corde
était tellement belle cette fête
exceptionnelle de l'aféas oui à l'une
d'elles reset total gabon
oui et six hôpitaux français c'est plus
ça pour ça totalement parce qu'il a une
raison politiquement laissant la langue
est plus capricieux la langue ibérique à
la tradition est plus petit la poésie de
pochoirs c'est que peut avoir un texte
premier degré en france exactement
totalement et des chansons les gens du
plan français qui était commandant
justement qui était un petit 2 secondes
après cela trois jeunes anglais était
comme ça fonctionne dans les textes
d'argile se fait juste le label électro
pop
non non elle a vraiment un bon génie
derrière elle son talent pour défaut
d'accord avec toi un plein parce que mes
enfants tout quand tu composes layton je
me suis tu tes écrits mais tu composes
aussi la musique oui oui joue du piano
piano jeu plus qu'un nul mais je suis là
ghetto simple et rapide d'europe 1 ce
samedi drapeau dans la composition
d'accord maintenant mais oui mon
processus d'écriture the masses au piano
puis ça dépend ça dépend des fois je
suis les accords blanche sauf que c'est
des baux accorde que je me dis dire est
une mélodie qui fêtera avec ça mais
l'apprentissage commence avec les
paroles parce que je suis dans mon c'est
l'écriture s'est énormément métaphorique
j'aime beaucoup ce même site en anglais
2 j'aime pas les impôts que j'aime pas
ça la gêne c'est écouter ça mais
l'écriture j'ai très perfectionné ce
fake des affaires de premier degré j'ai
l'impression que c'est jamais assez ce
qui n'est pas du tout vrai le pied je
sais qu'il ya beaucoup de personnes qui
est cliquée quand même pas les paroles
lautner m
gc c'est vrai quand quelque chose qui
plaît à radio tous les gens qui sont
capables qui chantent les paroles
washington mais que comme il apprend par
coeur pour les chanter et xavier charles
mais on dirait que pas le pompon
les banques sont à gauche
est-ce que tu t'entraînes c'est vrai
c'est tellement sont exactement ceux
affectés faut pas trop que je veux
mettre la pression là-dessus mais pour
mon propre désir personnel puis mon
besoin
j'écris des ch métaphorique puis je
m'applique énormément mais c'est drôle
si comme il ya beaucoup de monde qui
parlait de ça avec d'autres artistes
c'est la nuit que vient mon inspiration
forme élèves entre les murs comme le dit
georges écrit jean g8 sain et monkey
fait ensemble plage fait dans le texte
le lendemain je me réveille que j'ai
fait une chanson tu es passé des choses
qui arrivent c'est mon processus
d'écriture
waouh servir je lui écris le oui ça fait
longtemps que j'écris j'ai retrouvé des
vieux papiers gens de moins qui trouvait
sur le coin d'une table
et bonne dame ça serait de l'analyste
sur la croix et quand j'étais beaucoup
plus jeune c'est évidemment pour ces
pôles la direction je prends dans les
paroles et maintenant je suis quand
j'avais 12 ans mais ça ça fait très
longtemps que j'écris le fait que c'est
ancré en moi
ouais tu avais de ce fait d'autres
auditions de la voile d'autres années
j'ai fait j'ai fait l'année passée et
que les prix audition j'ai pas été
choisi pour tout puis je comprends
totalement je me sens pas choisi non
plus et commence à fonctionner sexta les
finales oui parce que c'est parce que je
talent et il était comme 7h30 du matin
gmt les premiers buts aller avec mon ami
et je l'accompagné je n'ai pas du tout
disposé de faire les autres sont la voie
moi en fait je m'étais dit que j'allais
pas les femmes et parce que je sais
poster pause 2-1 j'aime pas la
compétition de deux j'ai jamais fait
d'autres sont deux concours j'ai jamais
fait et je n'étais pas un enfant prodige
qui a 4 ans choisit des concours comme
chris neil et rapide qu'en mai jacob
guay kélian tcc des personnes qui a fait
de la voix et j'étais peut-être très
très j'ai pigé l'expliquent des fois
dans la voix mais j'étais très genre
refermer sur moi même jamais pas chanter
devant personnes chantaient à peine dans
ma douche c'est le monde il y avait
quasiment comme si le monde savait pas
tout que je chantais oui vraiment un
fake
des faits qui s'agrandit j'ai commencé
ce que je sois paul audy sentais plus
mon ami à se présente là dit le raf
choque un peu en dessous dessus et je la
fais pas dit je pense que ça s'est passé
à le dis je le fais pas si tu le fais
pas non parce que j'ai dit à qui veut
tuer le phare avec toi et moi j'étais
pour juste injuste pour les lalala lui
donner un peu de confiance
plus c'est long processus de la vois pas
ce que tu t'assois plus de se remplir
que seulement pendant une heure j'étais
convoqué dans quoi je me suis embarqué
si blake pour iphone qui fait que je
réponds question et tout mais moi
pendant ce temps là je me dis je me dis
pas que je m'en vais passer une audition
j'peux danse mining la pente au djé pas
préparé de chansons aucune idée de ce
que je vais faire je me présente au
comptoir plus la fille a dit bon quelle
chanson de refaire la voirie jeunes en
plein air
pas plus pas pensé plus que sa bravoure
à ce que je crois en mon dieu je sais
pas quelle chanson et moi qui étais
capable de prendre des décisions dans la
vie quand je balance mais je suis
incapable de partage
écoute le charme ont un fond bleu que
j'ai fait chauffer son iphone chambrer
sur une tonne de tory qui relie très
bonne mais pas d'epo parce que c'est là
que j'ai passé je sais pas c'est tout
pour avoir tout pour mettre toutes les
chances de mon côté je trouve un site ou
une toune de 7h30 du matin
voilà c'est un ami ce matin quand je
serai présent tout comme enchanté écoute
vraiment la paix gaffe que j'ai faite le
jeudi cette chanson love n'a mangé
je la pratique un peu avec la pianiste
parce que la bns du léman compagnie je
vois que je chante très mal mais je me
dis je vais y aller par est mon ami si
le matin des fautes tu chantes serov tu
es une grosse structure qu'elle a une
grosse voix leur sexy comme un grand oui
exact et là je me présente et je sais
pas mais j'ai perdu tous mes moyens
ce tarif il est arrivé là comme jeudi
j'étais pas préparés que j'avais jamais
fait dotation pour le concours fait que
je te laisse et quarté et moi qui est
une personne extrêmement stressé ce
pression qui incapables et ma voix
change complètement changé quand j'ai
quand je me sens et regarder quand je me
sens visé mais complètement donc je me
suis présenté et j'ai chanté comme une
truie s'est peut-être dit que j'étais je
m'entends je m'écoutais beaumont du raft
et dégueulasse mais pour vraiment en
toute connaissance de cause le vraiment
c'est pour rire à montréal j'étais
vraiment pour vraiment vraiment fait le
camp juste sorti de la chaleur mon dieu
à quel point je ne suis pas prise un
jour en plus mais risque encore sur
peuple est d'accord sur tout archives ac
v e mail gip ans qui ressortit à chaque
prime un vari tchèque et sophie
salama économies ont dû tomber sud la
différence là vraiment ça à moi je le
vois les gars de chez eux ça peut aussi
se rappeler de ce vraiment vraiment
poussé sait encore si c'est comme je dis
moi j'avais pas qu'il ressorte la mersey
les traditions l'année passée comment ça
s'est passé parce qu'il fonce à défaut
elle a de fait afin qu'il y faisait mais
l'a jamais vu césar est poursuivie même
si on voudrait c'est vrai c'est vraiment
mon dieu c'est vrai ayant tarawih j'ai
vu sur cette année un très gros sa femme
et pourtant que tu arrives tu arrives
tarn est tellement solide au plus bas
mais je trouve la merci des fins
médicales
on amène moi je veux pas jerry j'ai
regardé une toutes les prestations deux
fois maximum et un jeu puis regardez en
fait que je poste un peu comme poitiers
2 je peux clairement nous commençâmes
analysé parce que moi je m' analyse là
on veut on va vous laisser croire que
c'était parfait mais je mentalise
énormément piché vraiment exigeante fait
que jean genet coach l'a dit ou fait que
ça a toujours été comme ça puis je veux
toujours être comme ça malheureusement
je suis vraiment trop dur avec moi même
fait que j -p
j'ai pas l'impression que tu arrivée en
force à cause du stress parce que je
dire comme je dis je pars tous mes
moyens quand je stressais aux autres la
ville aux auditions auprès auditions et
au soutien aveugle aux prédictions le je
pensais pas que j'allais me faire
prendre parce que je me dis juste arrivé
à mes amis j'ai fait j'y serais tu pas
qu'on l'ait pas mal mais j'étais comme
j'ai schiste est pas bon le fake mais
bien plus c'est moi mon ex effet free a
fait il ya fait les autres signer pré
audition puis lui y ont été appelés deux
semaines avant moi pour se fabriquer à
la voix avec lui ça faisait deux
semaines que je savais que faisait la
voix je t'aime c'est ce qu' ils m'ont
yvon cher pour la foi mais non plus
comme nous l'apprend dessus tout cas
frêche aux lampions une que de nom
exactement le prouverai j'ai fait moi
c'est fou l'évolution que j'ai jg fait à
travers ce parcours le ca le pot de sens
on voit une énorme différence dans ma
confiance sur le stand jeter leurs
débuts et fm aux yeux mais au dernier
j'ai jamais été stressé comme ça c'est
vraiment moi j'ai plus le contrôle et le
prix audition autre salle aveugle et le
dernier c'est les 2 où j'étais le plus
stressé audition à l'aveuglé ç'a paru
dans mon contrôle et tout vocalement à
la fin aussi mais beaucoup moins que si
je savais beaucoup plus me tenir droit
puis faire simple incantation moyens
mais ouais mais écoutons sous la roche
rouge magenta chéquier comme ça je
perdais pied c'est sûr ce n'est pas
vraiment très très sain mon dieu et j'ai
jamais vraiment vraiment vraiment fou
secondes et pour se rappeler qu' on est
faux c'est fou le faut maîtriser c'est
ce qu'ont constante en candidature on a
une semaine pour apprendre notre chanson
il faut maîtriser à 200% notre chanson
pour examiner et on leur prend leur
parti oui je voulais faire c'est l'info
fait pas jouer les fasse maintenant
faufile bon le jeu mais je me pointe du
doigt les gens vont aller chaque et j'ai
fait un fin à un accord de marocains ok
mais s'il fait le mauvais accord le feu
s'est coiffé tabarnak
j'ai raté mon à coop se meut s'accrocher
dans et d'un doigt puis marc ils
entendent utiles comme la plupart des
gens qui connaissent la chanson c'est
pas du tout le bon d'accord l'appui
marqué maudit c'est là que j'ai su que
tu étais une vraie artiste parce que je
me suis dit comment va se reprendre ça
s'est tellement stressante et en live
c'est que gratter quelque chose en live
comprends c'est pas super qui s'est
passé mais j'ai écouté une fois faufile
là ça passe d'abord un peu je moi je
l'entend évidemment là mais je me suis
fait acquérir comme on ne peut pas faire
on reprend tout juste pour faire sauf
agrumes
j'ai continué mais finalement j'ai scoré
que la piano en chaussons membres tant
que c'est pas tant que ça parce qu'il ya
dedans mais ben corpo s'est affaissé
avec c'est bien là que j'ai fait le plus
de chou suis juste fait que je suis pas
musicienne pantone 100% ça pour sap
sicav parce que je la maîtrisait
parfaitement piano c'est facile et c'est
5 6 accor le sait rien mais le stress a
fait en sorte que mes doigts ce sens
j'étais perdu et s'est jetée comme plus
lol ah ouais tu voulais tourner que tu
es tellement joué le tage ou easy way
mais le sua claire stress vient comme
trop conscient que le tricot est plus il
faut absolument pas j'oublie l'accord
mais parfois c'est exact c'est que je
sais que c'est passé c'est over thinking
c'est vraiment ça qui me suis mise à
rouvres singh puis à partir de ce moment
là je me style avec coraf quand j'ai
fait la corde marre je me suis dit gars
faut pour prendre ces sommes c'est
maintenant ou jamais fait justement
voilà vit vraiment à présent c'est là
que je me rappelle je me rappelle pas
exactement c'était quand même je
rappelle que dans mon dans mon parcours
mettons à l'école 1 1
présentation orale
j'ai eu un moment déclic à ce que j'ai
fait tu apprends plus jamais un texte
par coeur oui à montanes sera plus
jamais un texte mot pour mot parce qu'il
est mieux que ta voix un texte mot pour
mot plus beau chapeau des baises à web
et times partout témoigne fini le web
comme un monologue ça allait vraiment
bien puis je donne ma confiance je
devais prasquier jour toute la fin de
ces sites sans arrêt j'ai même pas nîmes
et feuilleter jetaient le journal est ce
qu'il est vraiment à trop où trois cas
au phoque
j'ai un blanc qu'il était tellement
content j'étais même pas besoin
au sujet du monde a rappelé au monde est
conscient
je me souviens de ma faim je reste sur
la station proche wal mart a finalement
ce que je sais c'est quoi m'enfin c'est
fou piscine nous on a des boutons pour
les mettre les deux groupes
on a des démons terre avec les paroles
pour garder mais pour les pour l'automne
à nous ils veulent pas que ce soit une
béquille
parce que c'est fou mais des fois quand
tu sais que tu as les paroles qui fit
inconsciemment ou consciemment
constamment fait que tu regardes tous le
temple était moins concentrés et un fait
qu'il voulait pas nous donner nos
paroles pour nos chansons à nous mais je
sais qu'il ya une coupe de personnes qui
étaient stressés oubliée non mais
imaginé il ya même potts et soyaux
qu'une béquille flexibilité parole teint
blanc peloton avant tout chanter dans ma
vie dans surpris à quel point ça
n'arrive pas souvent
ouais quel point l'art dans les live à
la voix ça arrive pas quelqu'un qui fait
juste trop lente et la forme oui mon
sexe ça arrive pas messenger grippe
quelle belle au suivi puis sa palme à la
bonne santé car 1,6 à suivre est là mais
c'est l'adrénaline vraiment on m'a parlé
de ce type au jeu soci t elle la voix en
tant que tel instrument
techniquement le ton et j'en parlais
avec une technicienne kenzy l'année
passée il y avait un coq et hervé y
avait plus de voix 0 il est aimé
complètement le fil au lieu des
médicaments ça marche pas ça marchait
pas tout lui captain america est monté
sur scène
oui suppose-t-on ça marchait pas danser
il n'y avait aucun sens que certains
aient finalement il est monté sur scène
et avec la grâce de dieu pour cette
performance le sirop venus s'y fixer je
suis là mais c'est ça c'est vraiment
content et on sait on c'est fou le
mental ce qui suit c'est c'est beaucoup
plus puissante qu'on le pense là bas je
me souviens pas avoir vu quelqu'un sinon
non
c'est ça exactement moi on m'a dit que
personne qui a fait des craquements ou
des cris poussés dans sa future maman ça
arrive souvent dans l'aude en fermant
son doublé depuis son sacre à gouy non
non c'est fou ouais moi j'ai
l'impression
mais je savais pas que vous aviez
télésouffleur pour les autres persos
pour les libanais à 24h accès par la
mêlée patrick bruel exact beaucoup back
vocals beaucoup de cul ou c'est pas les
mêmes formes que les taux marginal puis
on avait le sto peut-être quatre cinq
jours avant infecter des jaloux taton à
prendre plus tôt jean 1 mai 2010 patrick
bruel pelotonne medley de 6 pi 2 simples
et fortes face des bacs sont elles qui
ont plutôt fait que c'est tellement de
sa quatre ans qu'ils se sont dit
inquiets pour lui tourne le groupe ça
paraît moins syriens sont les montants
pic et quelques paroles sont donnés il
n'a fait pour moi ils sont investis cet
espèce de
prologue ça nous rassure énormément
annoncé comme we say so ce qui
évidemment le plus important si jamais
tu entends back to back sur patrick
bruel assez fou fou fou fou shaker sa
part est d'apprendre une nouvelle tonnes
pour la finale oui oui c'est drôle mais
c'est sous le nez que c'est pour la
première mais si je ne m'abuse parce
qu'à la sortie on fait ce oui je sais
pas partir mais pourquoi ils ont pris
cette décision là mais je pense que
c'est bien parce que comme tu dis il ya
beaucoup de gens qui sont retournés aux
ressources puis qui ont fait une chanson
qui pourrait dans laquelle sont
confortables qui les touche énormément
si jessica vincent lui c'est une chanson
qui ça faisait longtemps qu'ils aiment
c'est une des ses chansons préférées
colin crazy la connaissaient comme
vraiment vraiment plus dans son élément
oui exactement to what if ex aussi ceux
ci le fun parce que tu décides la
couleur que tu peux donner à tata finale
c est exactement la chanson qui votent
avantages et parce que tu lui s'était
fait que c'est le fun que ce soit une
chanson qui existe déjà à la base puis
geneviève c'est une chanson qui l'a
ramenée à son québec à elle est tout
seul c'est vraiment le fun kimouche la
seule personne qui fait une chanson que
je connaissais pas la base puis je les
ai prises je les ai apprises en trois
jours oui mais set mais c'est ça qui est
spécial c'est ça qui est spécial avec
cette chanson là c'est que quand j'ai
entendu je me suis cassé ma tonne c'est
mathonnat moi c'est ma couleur c'est mon
style plus tard une biche plus - fort de
voix j'aime ça berthet j'aime ce faire
des défis défions safar comme ça je me
suis dit c'est le sait ce qui se
rapproche le plus de ce que je veux
faire dans la vie tu es fait que tu as
vu ça dans la tête des beatles qui
exactement
j'ai su que j'avais l'impression que la
connaissez la chanson quand je l'écouté
je connaissais évidemment je connaissais
celle des beatles
j'avais l'impression que je savais que
ça pouvait aller où
ouste aller avec un mois je les fais
pipi j'ai même pas eu à regarder les
paroles pour les apprendre
c'était déjà ancrée en moi je l'étais
deux fois piges je connaissais pas
repartir le fax et leur dire que c'est
vraiment une chanson pour moi ouais je
sais que tu avais tu avais l'appui de la
communauté vegan au complet c'est par un
coup j magie pour regarder ça parce que
j'ai ce deuxième en duché j'étais
ensevelie des messages
j'ai pas vu une application mais c'est
dans la cour oui surtout ce qu'ils font
c'est qu'ils m'ont donné une tribune
aussi la voix ils m'ont permis de parler
du véganisme ce que j'ai trouvé
absolument génial parce que dans un
épisode où il rentre un peu dans notre
vie pour à la voix extra ils sont venus
chez moi avec et j'étais en équipe avec
c'est l'entente décor de finale quand
j'étais avec faire l'ennemi ce qu'on
allait chanter le dimanche d'après les
trois contre j'aime pas ça veut dire
qu'on se comprenne qui aime et on décide
et nous nous y mener ensemble pour nous
trouver un espèce de deux points comme
un piquet on découvre chacun c'est quoi
tes et puis ce qu'on vivait dans nos
vies puis comme envoyé certaines choses
puis on est venu chez nous qu'on le fait
de la bouffe vegan sexuelle à la base
c'est le fun parce qu'on a découvert un
poster quoi pimmel puis faire l'union
manger j'ai fait un plateau de fromages
régale avec des idées cherki trévégat
pdd marmelade afin comme ceux qui ont
vraiment repris fait que ça c'est l'fun
pee wee puis à travers les deux heures
de tournage qu'on a fait et y ont pris
les lébous où je parlais de véganisme
qui je parlais de la raison pour
laquelle jal était devenu by l'éthique
animale politique environ
environnemental puis sa pensée à la télé
et puis à beaucoup m'ont écrit puis
monde y ait ce qui m'a fait réfléchir
nommément puis j'ai réduit ma
consommation bien nous je mange plus de
viande rouge devenu vert au mois d'avril
beaucoup de gens qui montent ce à cause
que c'est pas ça à la télé j'ai trouvé
cette noble de la porte de la voie des
mers sans lumière
vraiment vraiment parce que ça aussi le
potentiel de hausse est surtout un
public je sais pas mais c'est peut-être
une certaine passion leur public qui
veut rien savoir de ce exactement leur
montrer ce qu'il est pis que c'est
accessible j'ai fait ce tout en
respectant d'où sortent ces jets positif
où on est et on se comprend on est
toutes compréhensif dans la présente mal
mais j'étais moi j'ai trouvé ça vraiment
le fun qui garde soit parce que j'ai
parlé de bien d'autres choses aussi la
mairie c'est ce que je pensais ce qui
qui vieillit plus à chercher là qui plus
ancrée en elle fait que j'ai trouvé ça
vraiment cool c'est une décision quand
même risqué pour le public et le public
c'est la voit son émission qui
t'écoutent est partout sur ces régions
aussi exactement
j'ai eu des beautés bon feedback je
pense que c'est la manière dont il en a
dont ils ont amené le danger l'hernie
sauvetage les avants désavantageux pour
la communauté
puis d'autres monarchies je pense que je
me suis bien exprimé sur le sujet ben ça
a été très très factuelle fait que ce
projet fait qu'elle n'a plus trop de
frustrés non j'ai pas frustré ce que
j'ai trouvé très bon les gens en ont
pris mais j'ai pas eu de mauvais
commentaires si j'ai trouvé ce côté
quand s'est présentée jusqu'au matin
une facette d'une personne qu'on aime
pas pour ceux ci oui une personne qu'on
suit pas pour ça qu'en fait un ouais ben
khedda dharma nuit cette personne-là
cette habitude de vie le sait c'est
intéressant de s'informer exactement
exactement si ceux qui le font parce que
les gens avaient déjà appris à me
connaître
il y avait déjà appris à quoi ça va
connaître un peu ma personnalité
certains me suivait déjà avant la voix
saurait être sa g sa forte hausse au
fait qu' il y avait c'était des jeux
d'une malheurs d'une autre attaché je
pense à ma personne qui à mon talent
fait que le fait que je sois vegas et
post qui me déterminer au grand complet
malgré le fait que sa fille se soit une
grande grande partie nord je pense que
ils me faisaient déjà confiance avec le
fait que moi j'apporte en plus ces deux
dans ma personne ça a juste fait comme
or cette intéressante c'est ça c'est le
fun ouais ouais vraiment le connaître
des vagues
ça fait sept ans oui ça fait sept ans
suivait j'ai depuis que j'ai 7 ha ha
ouais ok ça goûte non mais je me suis
dit que je sais pas ça reste tout le
temps là j'en serai encore ses besoins
je n'en suis encore je me souviens
exactement ds les fromages que ça goûte
événements mais la viande le stijnen que
ça goûte les poulettes ou tu la quittes
l'appui à cette offre parce que mes post
parce que saint-amand le jeu lost et
sixt est vraiment animal
moi j'ai jamais vraiment aimé la viande
pour partir à cause du goût mais parce
que j'aime épaules je trouve que c'est
comment des gens même à 6 ans je sais
combien ces maisons c'est un peu un
animal j'ai vraiment fait
oui j'ai vraiment fait de l'ailier bowe
et vote l'allier bien monéger arrivé je
suis arrivé à mes parents que j'ai fait
on a des shows
je les mange pas pourquoi je mange le
poulet la maman a fait belle hausse qui
s'est ancré en nous un petit dans la
culture que j'ai fait mais je pas a dit
ok bah ouais c'était main cool je suis
tellement reconnaissante
j'ai plein de gratitude envers mes
parents dès demain pour la sefac soldats
bon prix une preuve décision à cet âge
l'enfant aurait souhaité un comme si
évidemment j'étais un humain à part
entière qui avait son doigt même à 7
intègre je trouve ça vraiment vraiment
le fun ces femmes à ma soeur à leucate a
enfin j'espère aussi son deuxième pas la
plus jeune l'aude l'aude à vanua lui a
décidé de ne pas manger de viande parce
que lui je sais pourquoi j'aime pas ce
message poste à cause qui fait lien sur
l'emploi y est encore petit mais mais il
sait que tout est légal
ouais ouais ouais ce truc c'est
l'influencé en fait je pense que je
pense que le fait que j'amène cette
question là dans famille off et
questionner ma soeur qui elle appréciera
mais ces questionnements la auprès de
ses enfants
oui qui peut dire que apprécions tin un
noah il s'attache les cheveux en arrière
c'est il veut pas moi je ne sens rien
manquer au cp pile au foyer tu es une
photo avec un marcheur membres une photo
il y avait un casse avait ses lunettes
il était sur son vélo ah ouais il
prenait la pose que j'avais une photo de
moi sur ma moto même pas s'il veut faire
comme tous les autres mais tu étais un
bel exemple pour les enfants ce qu'ils
font bah merci maman merci mme c c'est
davidsuzuki oui david tout ce qui
faisait que celui-ci starfire sont si
elle va refaire sa carrière
ouais il s'adresserait aux jeunes oui la
place de sites s'adresser aux adultes de
faire changer les habitudes des adultes
ir est direct à la génération à la
source
ouais je comprend 100% parce que l'autre
est ce parce qu'ils sont aux c'est plus
facile à convaincre d'un changement
parce que c'est moins
ancré à toi + pas juste pour le ski
environnementale autistes sans vote
direct aux jeunes qui eux n'ont pas
l'habitude vraiment écrire oui ils
prennent pas leur char à chaque jour à
l'épaule oui il ya beaucoup plus de
jeunes qui sont qui sont appelés les
porte-étendards de mouvements de ces
beaucoup plus que les adultes
malheureusement mais c'est plus facile
de faire des changements plus des jeunes
mais aussi les laissons plus
conscientisés puis avec les réseaux
sociaux il ya beaucoup
évidemment il ya moins de mal utiliser
mais aussi moyen de bien l'utiliser
oui dans tout ce discours là par rapport
à mon commentaire un auteur sur le
rapport est en ligne ses carnets les
réseaux sociaux c'est positif aussi des
temps big time cse et je trouve ça
tellement dommage que les gens utilisent
c'était accessibilité le pour des
derrière un écran
et parce qu'il est plus fort des
commentaires réagir si je peux m'en ce
qui me diraient pas en phase offensive
derrière un écran ils se permettent
d'avoir une opinion tellement tellement
tellement intense sur quelqu'un sans
vraiment à connaître la personne c'est
pile le dire la partager je trouve ça
vraiment plate et parce qu'il ya moyen
d'utiliser les réseaux sociaux d'une
tellement plus belle manière d'une
manière et levante pour en apprendre à
prendre des informations un pour
apprendre à connaître des mouvements
apprendre à connaître des personnes les
influences fait qu il ya vraiment moyen
d'utiliser les réseaux sociaux d'une
bonne manière a dit il ya beaucoup de
personnes qui trouvent que les réseaux
sociaux c'est le cancer de notre société
be qui devrait pas mais si c'est pas
tout noir ou tout blanc liège des ja
c'est ce qu'il ya du négatif puis j'en
ai reçus piget vous c'est tout c'est
juste pose toi des tableaux comment elle
a vécu elle à la source idéale aux reçus
peu négative quand même très peu levé
son duel qu'elle avait une robe quitter
wen
vraiment la robe vraiment pas sexy dans
sa robe était vraiment correct et c'est
loin d'être une robe rose et puis elle
est contre un groupe il y avait eu
certains commentaires déjà on sait bien
sûr les filles qui gong tous les mails
facebook et belle 90e et robes courtes
il n'avait plus beaucoup mais s'il peut
y avoir deux ou trois perchistes emprunt
mais oui mais comme si le talent et est
déterminé par la manière dont tu
t'habilles hélas apparemment saoul mais
si mais si c'est fou et en tant
qu'humain on a aussi cette espèce de
réflexion demain soir sans bon comment
table tu en a deux qui sont pas bons ton
cerveau automatiquement va s'accrocher
aux deux wii ne sont pas beaux accessits
arriver parce que c'était vraiment très
peu
c'est à pierre lapointe qui prennent la
décision l'an certain que guido polito
jugé sage applause mais non comme un
parent c'est comme ça s'appelle la voie
pour la robe mais sa robe était juste et
juste comme une robe de soirée courte et
normale n'était pas décolleté
merci pour ces mêmes jo dalla riva tout
nu on s'enflamme genre à poil
on s'en fout on sait ça détermine
potentats l'un c'est ce que je trouve ça
fou c'est ce que je comprendrai jamais
sur cette mentalité là jamais jamais
jamais mais le pays c'est mon ami a mis
knock le phare fait l'année d'après il y
en a et une chanteuse avec qui je la
musique souvent qui elle s était rendu
en demi finale cette année à l'équipe
d'ariane moffatt coin qui à l'époque les
juges donné les points qu'ils voulaient
un terme maintenant qu'un qui donne des
points c'est très presque égal à kiwi je
sais projet non je l'avoué je pense que
depuis cette époque des pistards le je
pense qu'il faut - il faut plus
attention donner des notes presque égal
ce public qui décide je comprends parce
que mettons à rien avait donné comme 65
points
ouf versus 35 alors qu'une grosse avance
qui le public avaient voté
majoritairement pour l'autre qui faisait
qui s'est le plus rock lopy plus je
potro puis elle avait chanté je pense
qu'il faut qu'elle a chanté l'hymne à
nous dans ce polar qu'elle avait chanté
par the world qu'elle avait joué la
baisse
non non non non ça avait perdu ce soir
c'est l'autre d'avancé entre les deux je
me suis fais quoi son nom ce qu'ils
m'auraient dit lino ramelli non elle à
l'inversé de la marne et pour vous c'est
les pythies digestive d'affaires déjà
ils couchent ensemble les oublier son
nez elle savait thereof parce que
c'était je t'aime beth quand même comme
toi laisse tes potes du trop fort si
c'était toi même il faut tellement sa
peau de sens faute faut s'en détacher
puis c'est ce que j'ai c'est ce que j'ai
compris avec ça parce que moi je fais
partie des réseaux sociaux
parlant comme doute peut-être 3,3 gadjo
gens parce que je voulais protéger mon
coeur parce que c'est ma façon à moi
j'avais sauf si cela m'était jamais
ajoutent-ils toujours eu du positif dans
ma vie oui c'est ça parce que j'ai fait
la meilleure performance finale jours
exactement fait moi je voulais juste me
concentrer sur la salle est exactement
pis mais j'ai réalisé avec avec l'épaule
le plus de temps que j'ai pensé à foxy
sont moins qu' il fallait pas que je
donne de l'importance à ces gens là
parce que ça vous juste pour la peine
parce que je me dis que je me dis j'en
suis venu à me dis qu'est ce que j'ai
fait de mal je ne comprends pas j'ai
juste des bonnes intentions je vais
peut-être justement pas blesser personne
puis j'ai pris pas gagné parce que j'ai
troqué la chose que j'ai payé les gens
tu comprends ces lieux brut et reed
complot c'est exactement penser que
c'est truqué parce qu'il y avait du
monde qui avait de la misère à a voté
pour lui mais moi toute ma famille qui
est un souhait personnel qui réussit à
voter pour moitié ça a été ça pour les
causes de collines maudit et mon l'app
store de ma famille on pourrait dépendre
des pas capable un fait ça c'est juste
c'est trop il ya d'autres personnes dans
le réseau si c'est juste une question
technique mais j'ai loin il faut juste
pour donner de l'importance à ces
personnels ça vaut pas la peine tu
connais ta valeur il faut que tu tank
pourtant nombre puisqu'ils savent
toujours être comme ça tu peux pas
plaire à tout le monde mais ce que je me
dis c'est que moi personnellement jamais
je ferai ça jamais j'irai bâché sur
quelqu'un gens aussi même si georges je
trouve ça change vraiment pas bien je
m'en fous gens je regardais ce promo je
m'en fous genre à quoi ça sert
notamment que je pense qu'on a tous des
besoins comprendre là tu as vraiment
beaucoup de gens j'ai bâti vraiment déjà
tellement oui vraiment c'est tellement
important pour eux que ça change quelque
chose picot qui comme si comme s'il
pensait que ça va faire plaisir à eric
oasis heures de mes meilleurs amis
moi je suis juste il dit il y était
comme grave je m'excuse tellement
j'arrive ou jamais jamais voulu que le
monde le beh iman pillet monte à l'enppi
les dom et on était là ensemble ces
buts-là fasse pas comme sont des ennemis
non plus qu'on se lancer des flèches le
fait que ça ça peut faire plaisir avec
non plus payant il le dit ce sont 1 100
g je vais jamais tolérer ce genre de
commentaire là les gars de raphaël puis
toutes ces gérants aussi ses amis en ont
fait des commentaires ya beaucoup
d'articles sont sortis ou city mais des
fous s'il ne faut juste pas accorder
d'importance à son piquant quand écrire
ce genre d'affaires l'espace quitté
l'yonne par titouan kiki malheureuse ses
piges
c'est peu importe c'est quoi qui fait en
sorte qui poussa à faire sauter il faut
et réfléchissons avant d'écrire des
choses n'a aucun sens ce qui fait qu'ils
sont là la difficulté avec la voix sait
que c'est tellement gros d'un coup ouais
que topol temps de préparer roland c'est
quelqu'un que ça fait longtemps qu'il
fait ce mets ton mari est habitué ça
fait longtemps qu a fait super haletante
se construire tout en tout cas la
wattine homme qui n'était pas connu
qu'est gobain là c'est trop chaud la
plus grosse visibilité que tu aurais
jamais été pour la plupart exact il le
sait comme dit oui c'est ça exactement
piteux peut pas particulièrement les
outils pour sauter mais j'ose même pas
imaginer avec odessa a été comment parce
que nous commençons déjà dit c'est un
peu par étapes avec des jeux là j'avais
le temps d'accumuler certaines certaine
connaissance fine marché mais toi suffit
cependant ce que deux mots c'est quand
même trois mois trois mois et sa
patience qui le tati terme et on arrive
d'automne
aucune reconnaissance du public puis
sort de l'hôpital genre 150000 personnes
tuées sur instagram sa peau de santé
comment ces vies c'était si j'avais à
leur fin ouais je ferais différemment
maintenant la façon avec laquelle j'ai
abordé la patente heureusement que je me
serais mais très éloignées des réseaux
sociaux
un bouquet vraiment j'aurais juste faire
comme non non c'est quand je me
retrouvais mois avant d'être la personne
que c'est tellement tellement tellement
malheureuse si j'avais si j'avais eu à
leur forme mais c'était cette étude
c'est un métier tu sais mais je vais en
parler ça fait deux jours la finale la
voile est encore là d'un sujet martelé
vécu mais c'est so you think i mode en
l'expérience que j'ai vécue apport le
retour du public loin dans l'expérience
la voix j'ai rien vécu qui monument
assommé autrement c'est en principe
aussi fait ça il est facile pour moi les
retours du public pour cet épisode là
dans ces périodes qu'on reste amis
puisque pour le show et puisqu'elle là
on va encore faire des choix sentiment
n'est est menacée et qu'ils sont c'est
moins et puis moi pineau talents sont
pas comparables puisque correct on
préfère un maire monétique bref on se
comprend mais ils y ont déjà eu lieu du
monde qui sont passés sur le camp
geneviève évidemment c'est inévitable
quand quelqu'un gang des gens qui sont
fâchés parce que c'est pas leur préféré
qu à gagner
je rappelle aux gens qui est un pont qui
sait que c'est important malgré le fait
que tu aies une préférence ce corps et
des déçus j'aurais voulu que colin gones
enfin une excuse mais même quand même
écrit un message la team moi je me suis
prononcé à ce sujet puis vincent pensent
la même chose c'est important comme je
disais de porc abc quelques heures parce
qu'on préfère un autre fait juste vivre
chez toi public en gratuit date c'est
tout et c'est juste une émission télé ça
ne détermine pas le talent de quelqu'un
aussitôt gagné ou pas à quelque sheures
une compétition nautique définitivement
pas pour revenir sur ce qu'on disait de
faire avec les les
l'aspect positif des réseaux sociaux je
voyais passer dernièrement je pense que
justement c'est jessica partager ce une
story qui disait repenser la façon vous
utiliser les réseaux sociaux
tellement tellement hâte à menton
d'utiliser les pommes - utiliser les
mieux allez suivez du monde qui vous
inspirent ces visions positives semaine
de quoi il se troue sauf j'trouve ses
fautes et intéressant comme façon dont
les choses moi si je passe à travers mon
fils
instagram en ce moment de pur md abonnés
sûrement de 50% que je suis moi je te
remplacer ce monde le parent du monde
qui ont des trucs qui m'intéresse est
détruit ils vont acheter quelque chose
de twihome amener ailleurs c'est fini
puis je pense que c'est un exercice
oui c'est vraiment c'est tellement une
influence plus que tu penses qu'ils te
suit qu'est ce que l'humain et influença
même si concède un peu j'essayais même
ce constat repos quelqu'un qui est
facilement influençable parce qu'ils ont
chacun des chacals et nature différente
l'instinct de l'humain c'est de
s'adapter à son environnement
quand même des animaux they kiss a
toujours été sobre ça va toujours être
ce fake
malgré consciemment ou inconsciemment de
susi que comme puits qui tient avec un
tel cercle d'amis ce stade a pas comment
ils ont fait
c'est bien c'est bien mais portant de
s'exposer à des personnes qui sont
positives qui 30
kiki qui t'amène un autre niveau et que
tu t'es alimenter un power in c'est
vraiment important fixe et d'un meilleur
exerça femme je pense que je le fais
aussi je pense je pense vraiment que
tout le monde gagnerait à essayer de si
tout le monde dans le métro maintenant
matin il tombe sur ils font je suis fait
un fait qui les amène à réfléchir minuit
à être meilleure personne à être plus
heureux à apprendre plus de soin de soi
même de sa santé mentale physique pas le
kit tout le monde et je suis mieux oui
parce que c'est qu'il est encore un
autre cela fer de l'arctique 2
des potins a montré en personne en
partie son influence est vraiment pas la
peine d'alimenter ce vraiment sympa même
si activement tulipes au sol est
constitué
oui s'il voit paré et pis c'est
important se protéger puis de postes
exposés à ce vraiment parce que cette
influence de manière ou d'une autre ça
pollue terme en gâcher ta journée
totalement c'est con mais c'est vraiment
c'est conscient ou inconscient mais
c'est vraiment cela dans un mois quand
j'étais journée mais ça va
tranquillement avec le temps définir les
personnes qui étaient totalement si vous
à tous les citoyens du monde qui pose
des affaires anti-musulmans un jour ça
pour ça jour après jour après jour après
jour à la longue ça va devenir sa
personne lointain mais ces foules un
coup je te vanter à le danger inverse
amanissi de vivre dans cet exposé aucune
arguments qui nous déplaît tonnes en mai
mais c'est important quand même de
rester alerte aux choses négatives qui
peuvent nous c'est fini
puis nous atteindre pin ou à long terme
définies
total a justement d'accord avec ceux qui
aussi cette nuance le de savoir aussi
s'exposer à des choses qui nous sort de
notre zone de confort qui nous font
vouloir s'améliorer en tant qu'humain
puis se remettre en question tes posts
précédents comme s'ils disaient l'asbl
où tu veux rien apprendre parce que tu
veux rester dans ton confort aussi c'est
important d'y aller mais tout le temps
tout le temps positivement de savoir ce
qui se passe dans le monde tout en se
protégeant en s'exposant pas des
affaires qui sont totalement futile dont
au public et aux pas besoin de savoir
totalement là dessus ouais ouais je suis
vraiment d'accord avec sally bowles
repensons réponses sont les faces way et
jesse à le thème a raison mais c'est
tellement seule vraiment ouais merci
beaucoup à obtenir six avoue stade dans
belfort
ben on avait les jambes suivent partout
resta gramercy de sûreté martin 2 sur
tout
certaines d'autres marques
j'ai joué avec marquis est checké les
dates de marc pasquet devons être le
nouvel présent déjà riche ou avec la loi
expérience la voie à wawa la wii avec
mes collègues la plupart de mes
collègues qui ont fait la voix avec moi
ça va être un simple décodeur
je veux chanter avec rick qui jouent
chantent avec du monde à la voile c'est
un mec très mal fans très cool merci
[Musique]